in the aftermath of elon musk winning
approval from twitter's board to buy the
company for 44 billion dollars
tesla shareholders showed their doubts
shares of the electric car maker fell
nearly 12 on april 26th
erasing nearly 130 billion dollars from
tesla's market cap
this took out 29 billion dollars from
musk's fortune in less than a day
this happened because most of musk's
fortune lies in his 21 stake in tesla
when musk first proposed a hostile
takeover of twitter on april 14th
analysts pointed out concerns musk could
be forced to pledge tesla shares as
collateral for loans to buy the social
media company some of those fears have
come to fruition as part of the 46.5
billion dollar financing package musk
revealed on april 25th he will pledge
62.5 billion dollars worth of tesla
stock to secure a 12.5 billion dollar
margin loan
and prior to going after twitter
musk had already pledged more than half
his stake in tesla as collateral for
other loans
on top of a 13 billion debt commitment
from banks which will partly be secured
by twitter itself musk also told
twitter's board he will pay for 21
billion dollars of the purchase with
equity however it's not yet clear where
that cash will come from forbes
estimates musk has about 2 billion
dollars of cash on hand after selling
over 16 billion dollars worth of tesla
shares late last year
paying taxes on those sales donating six
billion dollars to a charitable entity
and paying 2.6 billion dollars to
acquire his initial twitter stake
earlier this year